blad Smiths welcome to the forge we
found some springs for you guys to use
to make signature blades in your
signature style good luck your
three-hour Starts Now I decide to try
canister Damascus some people use white
out to create kind of a wall between the
canister and the inside materials but I
decided to try using a different method
Z has actually heated up his can right
away which seems weird because isn't
there going to be Forge scale all inside
of that
I just let it oxidize a little bit and
kind of form a layer on the inside and
hopefully that will keep the insides
from sticking to the canister I'm happy
with springs I don't have to tear
anything
apart I'm going with the three smaller
Springs because there's less to mess
with them easier to fit in the
can it's important to to be working
efficiently keep it
simple once I get the Springs cut down
to size uh I throw them in the can
packing it full of 1095 powder
we've got Chris at the welding station
he will be the first of our Smiths to be
welded up and Into the
Fire I've made several knives out of old
car springs and stuff I don't think it's
going to be all that crazy a knife's a
knife I'm going to take the largest
spring cut it into three sections
straighten them all out clean them up
take the other two Springs smaller
Springs and wrap them around each other
and four dwell them all together around
the main buet I got my w set on the
Press now I'm ready to draw my can out
into more of a Billet shape I decide to
leave my canister on and hope that the
forge scale that I built up earlier is
not an interference once I start
pressing my canister I know things are
welding because once it starts
consolidating it almost hardens
up now Chris actually took his canister
to Big Blue my concern is he went one
pass on the press and then to the hammer
and we've seen that cause cracking in
buets before hot metal here we go oh
this is going to be nice here we go it's
got a snake like coil like a hot boa
constrictor and you can see it
moving I got all the well starting set
almost one homogenous piece of Steel so
now I got to turn this thing into a
knife Rocky just
quenched it's good and straight The Edge
should be really hard go back to the
grinder and get this thing clean up up
to the judges
now I got the basic shape to my blade
and I decided to grind away as much of
this mild steel can to reveal the uh
pattern underneath I have 15 minutes
left on the clock I'm ready to
quench it's fairly straight I think it's
okay so I get my blade nice and hot and
now it is ready to be dunked in the
oil
Doug how does zay's blade look it's
refined looks pretty good my Edge is
hard I don't know about the rest of my
blade but hopefully that's all it'll
take for me to pass 5 4 3 2 1 blade
Smith shut down your machines drop your
tools this first round of competition is
over blade Smiths Welcome to our
strength test the oil barrel stab and
chop to test the tip Edge and overall
constr destuction of your weapons I'm
going to take your blades and repeatedly
and mercilessly chop and beat into these
oil drums and Chris you're up first how
you feeling okay all right let's do
it we're not done
yet
all right Chris everything's tight you
lost the slightest bit of your tip and
on your Edge the only thing that's
missing is The Edge very good job thank
you okay Zan after seeing that how do
you feel a little bit nervous but
excited to see what happens so am
I
good job Zane for the batoning it was
difficult because you've got a drop here
so a couple times I'd hit and glance but
when it went through it punctured down
good distance this is one of the reasons
I'm wearing a glove blowing through that
pocket this will tear your finger up but
your tip and Edge held up fine good job
thank you judge Rocky how you feeling
nervous it's all right I'll be calm for
both of
us
[Music]
Rocky your tip held up fine and your
Edge held up fine the handle a little on
the Square side and your Pummel
separated that's a bit of an issue but
overall your blade survived good job
thank
you
all right blad Smiths to find out how
sharp your edges are the leather vest
stab and
slice Chris you're first you ready for
this yes sir let's do
this
all right Chris let's talk about your
blade here and it's not very sharp when
you're slashing the sheer weight of your
blade here does cut it but doesn't
lacerate it nicely but overall sir for
this test it will come thank you sir all
right Zane you're up ready yes sir let's
do
this
[Music]
all right Zay talk about your blade here
the grinds that you have on this Edge
are sharp so it's able to cut the
leather now stabbing your point does
penetrate deeper in all the way through
there the one issue I had here is the
guard the angle that you have of your
curve there actually drives my hand to
go forward as opposed to holds me back
from going any deeper than that but
overall surf it will cut thank you
dog and then there was one are you ready
Rocky I'm ready let's do
this
all right Rocky let's talk about your
weapon right here your Pummel was
already loose before we started didn't
get any worse the Edge by slashing with
a tip it did cut on one side of the vest
cleanly on the other side it just ripped
it the edges right here are not as sharp
as I would have expected it to be but
overall sir for this test it'll be cut
thank
you all right blade Smiths I finished my
conference with the judges and they
agreed that none of your blades are
perfect each of them has flaws
unfortunately
Rocky your Pummel came loose during a
strength test and let's just face it
most of your finer knives don't have any
moving parts for that re reason I have
to ask you to please leave the
forge so I'm feeling a little
disappointed but I represented myself
well thank you I've learned a lot about
myself should have been better that's
amazing what this clock would do to you
I'm only going to stop blaz with him
like it's getting too old to pick up at
Hammer to work with
[Music]
it